ليلة 34 من هذه الحرب جلبت الجحيم إلى
مستشفيات غزة، الموت قريب جدًا بالنسبة لهؤلاء
المسعفين خارج المستشفى حيث تلوا
صلواتهم الأخيرة، يقول المستشفى إن العديد من
الجرحى في هذه الضربات
وتضررت سيارتي إسعاف بالكامل،
وكانت واحدة من عدة مستشفيات ضربت
في ما كان  ليلة رعب لأولئك الذين
يحتمون في المرافق الطبية في
شمال
غزة، وفي يوم الجمعة، جاء المزيد من وجع القلب
مع هذه المشاهد المدمرة في
مجمع مستشفى الشفاء. الصرخات المؤرقة لأولئك
الذين نجوا من هذا الانفجار في حالة ذهول وهم
يبحثون عن أحبائهم بين
القتلى
وصور الجرحى التي أثارت الغضب  العاملين في المجال
الإنساني مثل الدكتور النرويجي ماتز
جيلبرت الذي تطوع في الشفاء في
الماضي الرئيس بايدن السيد
بلينكين السيد بلينك هل تسمعني
يا رؤساء الوزراء ورؤساء
الدول الأوروبية هل يمكنك سماعي هل
يمكنك سماع صرخات
مستشفى الشفاء من المستشفى هل يمكنك سماع
هذه صرخات الأبرياء
اللاجئين الذين يحاولون العثور على
مكان آمن يتعرضون للقصف من قبل
الهجوم الإسرائيلي الذي يفرض على المستشفيات التي هي
معابد الإنسانية
والحماية ولكن هذه حرب بلا
خطوط حمراء والمستشفيات ليست ملاذا
لعشرات الآلاف المحشورين فيها  هذه
المستشفيات يائسة من أن تكون محمية من
حرب لم
تشهدها غزة على الإطلاق منذ أسابيع، وكان الجيش الإسرائيلي
يدعو المدنيين إلى التحرك جنوبًا
للخروج من طريق الضرر، كما يقولون، لكن
الكثيرين كانوا مترددين في تسخين هذه
الدعوات بالغارات الجوية و  تبعت الموت
جينس إلى الجنوب، ولم يكن هناك مكان
آمن في هذه
المنطقة المحاصرة، ولكن مع قيام الجيش الإسرائيلي
بفتح ممر إنساني وسط
قتال عنيف في الشمال،
لم يكن أمام عشرات الآلاف من خيار سوى الفرار في مشاهد
تثير ذكريات مظلمة للفلسطينيين عن
الهجرة الجماعية من  العقود الماضية
لم تكن هناك عودة منها ولكن لا
يستطيع الجميع مغادرة القتال، وقد
حاصر القتال بعض الأشخاص الأكثر ضعفاً في
مستشفيين للأطفال حيث
يحتمي المئات ويطالب الأطباء
اللجنة الدولية بإجلائهم.
القوات الإسرائيلية في الخارج مباشرة وتدير
المستشفيات
بالعودة إلى داخل الشفاء، لا يوجد توقف
ولا توقف لأولئك الذين يقومون بمهمة لإنقاذ
الأرواح، يبحث الأب بفارغ الصبر عن
الأطباء للحصول على أخبار جيدة فقط ليُقال له إن
ابنه الصغير قد
رحل ولم يشعر جينس أبدًا بأنه مهجور
وحيدًا في أرض الموت واليأس هذه.